aquel fatídico 15 de febrero
impetrópolis Y llovió impresoras más de
lo que se esperaba para todo el mes los
deslizamientos dejaron 235 muertos
desde entonces la ong sos Serra ayuda a
las familias necesitadas entregando un
millar de canastas solidarias por mes
en estas canastas hay arroz frijoles
aceite harina de yuca harina de maíz
pasta normalmente para una familia de
cuatro personas alcanza un mes
hoy Carolina lleva las provisiones a
shakhraflora una comunidad que fue
totalmente devastada por las lluvias
[Aplausos]
en este barrio encaramado en la montaña
23 personas perdieron la vida
el rastro de la destrucción todavía Es
evidente en una ciudad donde el 30% de
los habitantes vive en áreas de riesgo
por la falta Crónica de vivienda
esta mujer perdió a seis miembros de su
familia y puesto callejero de comida
mi mayor problema ahora es el trabajo Yo
me esfuerzo trabajo como limpiadora hago
pequeños trabajos estoy consiguiendo
sobrevivir
desde estas pantallas la protección
civil controla si los ríos se desbordan
el ayuntamiento ha creado un protocolo
de evacuación ante la imposibilidad de
realojar a todos los vecinos en riesgo
toda la población tiene que ser
entrenada este es nuestro mayor desafío
paralelamente a las obras públicas
los expertos coinciden en que esta
tragedia es un reflejo del cambio
climático y que puede repetirse
petrópolis lucha para recuperar la
normalidad